foreign
[Music]
to our new original this week we talk
about a film that is right at the top of
many fans wish lists The Amazing
Spider-Man 3 the sequel that should have
completed the trilogy starring Andrew
Garfield the reality is well known
because so far there are only two movies
with Garfield Spider-Man and for the
time being he was superseded by Tom
Holland for the MCU yet today we want to
ask ourselves what a lead sequel to the
film series could look like and why
another part may not be so unlikely in
the future enjoy
if we look at the two predecessors we
can derive a certain direction for The
Amazing Spider-Man 3. the first The
Amazing Spider-Man movie with Andrew
Garfield was released in 2012 something
that immediately stands out especially
in the year 2022 is that the film's
title alone sets it apart from the other
two film series starring Toby Maguire
and Tom Holland Garfield Spider-Man is
thus obviously based more on the comic
book with the same title which has been
published since 1963 and is by far the
most widely distributed comic book from
the Spider-Man universe from its
establishment in 1963 to the 700th issue
in 2012 the comic book was consistently
published and is accordingly extensive
the other two franchises are also based
more or less on these Comics but those
responsible always use the original in a
slightly different way and at times
Incorporated a great deal of artistic
freedom however the comic book original
is not the reason that the Amazing
Spider-Man 3 is once again a big Topic
at least among fans the hype surrounding
Garfield undoubtedly stems from the
release of Spider-Man no way home about
a year ago when many were taken back to
the old days by the universe spanning
reunion of the three Peter Parkers but
back to the beginnings of The Amazing
Spider-Man the first of two parts was
released in 2012 and thus exactly five
years after the trilogy with Toby
Maguire and five years before the
trilogy with Tom Holland Peter Parker is
initially a typical teenager who lost
his parents at an early age and is
living with Uncle Ben and Aunt May his
father was a renowned genetic researcher
and a left behind briefcase eventually
leads Peter to former business associate
Dr Kurt Connors who was researching
cross-species genetics at Oscorp
Industries as a supposed intern there
Peter is bitten by a radioactive spider
giving him his superpowers he seeks out
Connors and ends up working with him as
in the film series with Tobey Maguire
here too Uncle Ben is shot by a robber
after an argument with Peter this
triggers great feelings of guilt in the
young Peter and results in him becoming
a masked superhero to make the streets
of New York City a little safer in
addition there is of course again a
crush on the main character who here is
not called Mary Jane or MJ but Gwen
Stacy over the course of the story Dr
Kurt Connors turns out to be a villain
who after self-testing a regeneration
serum transforms into a superhumanly
fast and strong lizard the so-called
lizard then intends to subject the
city's inhabitants to the same fate but
has stopped at the last minute by
Spider-Man tragically Gwen's father
George dies in the process and in his
last minutes begs Peter to keep his
daughter out of trouble the second part
titled The Amazing Spider-Man 2 picks up
directly where the previous part ended
and First shows the turbulent superhero
existence in the urban Canyons of New
York City at first more clarity is
brought to the mysterious death of
Peter's parents and later we get to see
him and Gwen trying to reconcile their
love lives with his existence as a
superhero things also go their way at
Oscorp Gwen has the chance to intern
there and Peter saves the life of
company electrician Max Dillon moreover
company president Norman Osborne dies of
a strange disease that has also spread
to his son in the meantime the rescued
electrician from the beginning of the
film has fallen into a tank of electric
eels and us has been involuntarily given
superpowers after he's captured by
Spider-Man and admitted to the infamous
ravencroft Institute he begins to
develop a strong hatred for Spider-Man
Harry Osborne meanwhile sees the Oscorp
spider's venom as the last resort to
cure his terminal illness Peter however
refuses to donate blood because of
unclear implications which leads Harry
in desperation to release Electro and
with his help obtain the Spider Venom on
oscorp's premises this transforms him
into the Green Goblin and a final
showdown ensues between the former best
friends unfortunately Gwen Falls victim
to the final fight which in turn Peter
does not cope well with giving up his
superhero existence for a while he does
however return to fight the villain
Rhino recruited by Harry with the
outcome still being unclear
now that we've refreshed our memories of
the two The Amazing Spider-Man films
let's turn our attention to the
potential plot especially because of the
open ending of part two there are enough
options to follow up with a third movie
that it is technically and legally
possible to bring back Andrew Garfield
is something we have known since no way
home at the latest a parallel universe
alongside the one with Tom Holland is
also conceivable outside the MCU and as
before at Sony Pictures there is one
drawback however by the time the Amazing
Spider-Man 3 is released Garfield will
be at least 10 years older than before
and well into his 40s so there won't be
much left of the youthful Spidey
Aesthetics by then it would therefore
not make any sense for the new film to
immediately pick up where the
predecessor left off unless the final
battle against rhino had taken such a
toll on him that he had aged many years
in the meantime so the plans for a
sequel that were made back then are
rather useless that's why we're now
looking to a few hints about a possible
alternative storyline based on various
sources as early as 2015 George Stacy
actor Dennis Leary talked about the
proposed plot in an IGN interview
according to the interview he himself
would have played a role in the third
part in spite of his death on screen the
idea circulated that Spidey could revive
his deceased companions through a
mysterious magic formula with which he
could bring back George his girlfriend
Gwen and presumably also his Uncle Ben
indeed this idea sounds completely
absurd and would probably have been
dismissed as complete nonsense if not
for the statement of an actor involved
however there is actually at least some
justification for it in the comics
through Professor Miles Warren AKA
Jackal various Spidey clones were
created from Peter's DNA in the original
the same could be done with Gwen and
other deceased characters this story arc
already divided the fan base when the
comic was released as it almost makes
things too easy and takes away the
impact and significance of the previous
deaths in 2017 director Mark Webb also
spoke about the planned plot two years
after the Amazing Spider-Man franchise
was signed off according to his
statements he also deceased Norman
Osborne who was embodied by Chris Cooper
at the time would have returned in a
significantly larger role than before in
the third part he would have taken over
the the role of the Green Goblin from
his son after he came back from the dead
the main villain would have been Gustav
Fierce aka the gentleman who had no
direct superpowers but can make up for
it with his wealth and tricks later he
would have led the Sinister Six in the
spin-offs finally we would like to
mention the role of Emma Stone as Gwen
Stacy Not only would she have returned
as Peter's girlfriend but later she
would have taken on the role as the
villain carnage this would have adapted
storylines from the Ultimate Comics and
certainly created an exciting
constellation Garfield himself also
commented in The Amazing Spider-Man from
time to time during the years sometimes
he denied further participation due to
his age other times he expressed his
wishes for a hypothetical The Amazing
Spider-Man 3. among these is a clash
between Spidey and Eddie Brock AKA Venom
as he confirmed in the happy sad
confused podcast earlier this year
additionally there was already fan art
showing him in a symbiote costume that
would certainly come in handy when
fighting Venom much like in Spider-Man 3
with Tobey Maguire at a cost of course
in summary there are various ideas about
the storyline that don't stem from the
image nation of the fans but rather from
the statements of the people involved
and the comics
let's take a brief look at the
production background of The Amazing
Spider-Man 3. basically Sony didn't want
to leave it at a pure Trilogy around the
friendly neighborhood spider but instead
wanted to initiate an extensive
franchise in 2013 the third film was
announced with a theatrical release in
2016 and two years later the fourth part
of the main series was supposed to kick
off in addition two spin-offs were
planned for the Sinister Six as well as
Venom and Carnage the directors Drew
Goddard and Alex kurtzman were also
already confirmed the spin-offs were to
be released in parallel to the main
series the plans for the Saudi franchise
outside the MCU were therefore quite
ambitious and the reflections were well
Advanced to Sony's utter astonishment
however The Amazing Spider-Man 2
performed poorly at the box office and
generally received mixed reviews as a
result screenwriter Roberto orsi a
pivotal member of the team left the
pre-production team to work on Star Trek
Beyond thus the situation was
unfavorable and the movie was pushed
back further in November 2014 the hacker
group Guardians Of Peace infiltrated
Sony pictures and leaked a large number
of internal documents alongside various
emails between high-ranking employees
these also included details about the
Amazing Spider-Man it was revealed for
example that Emma Stone was in talks to
return in The Amazing Spider-Man 3 after
which her character Gwen would have been
resurrected in addition further films by
Sam Raimi were planned and even initial
ideas for a future Crossover with Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire were being
discussed however the subsequent
negotiations between Sony and Marvel
over future film rights did not go in
favor of The Amazing Spider-Man and
ultimately put an end to the
far-reaching dreams of those responsible
instead in 2015 both parties concluded a
deal that Spider-Man would move to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the future
which effectively put an end to the
Amazing Spider-Man as the Sony franchise
ironically the renewed hype around Sony
Spider-Man was created by Marvel's
Spider-Man no way home at the end of
2021 and the speculations took off we
still don't know whether the Amazing
Spider-Man 3 will ever be released there
are several conflicting statements
circulated however one should not forget
that Garfield denied his involvement in
the film in the run-up to Spider-Man no
way home more or less credibly and we
all know what the end result was so we
shouldn't give up hope for another The
Amazing Spider-Man
we hope you enjoyed our new original
episode about a possible The Amazing
Spider-Man 3 and would appreciate it if
you shared the video with your friends
How likely do you think a continuation
of the film series with Andrew Garfield
is and which roles and storylines would
you most like to see feel free to tell
us in the comments
[Music]
thank you